there is a new coveted booster headed to
pharmacies around the country it is
designed to fight the omicron variants
responsible for the most coveted cases
in recent months here to break it down
dr celine gallander editor at large for
kaiser health news and a cbs news
contributor dr gowner good morning good
to see you uh nate is back with us
because he has some questions for you dr
gallander
i do dr gallander it's good to see you
now for people whose last covet shot was
a while ago maybe even last year is this
the booster update that they've been
waiting for
big picture if you are 12 and up
and you have received your primary
series you might have even been boosted
if you're 12 and up you are eligible for
an updated omicron vaccine
i would
make that advice a little bit more
nuanced for people who want a slightly
more tailored approach so if you are 50
and up if you are immunocompromised you
should get that omicron booster as soon
as possible
if you're under 50 if you're healthier
the real benefit of getting that omicron
booster is not so much protecting
yourself or keeping yourself out of the
hospital but rather to protect other
people and so if you are planning to see
perhaps older family members other
people with medical conditions over the
holidays you might want to delay getting
that booster until two to four weeks
prior to the holidays but again
everybody 12 and up is eligible for an
omicron booster right now
okay so speaking of uh delaying getting
the booster i recently had covet i'm
okay now for everybody who's wondering
but i'm vaccinated i'm boosted so should
i wait and how long should i wait if i'm
going to get the omicron booster or
should i get it at all
the the way the fda and the cdc have
recommended have authorized the omicron
boosters they are saying two months
delay between either a vaccination or an
infection
but if you actually look at the
immunological basic science studies it's
really three months or more so the
advice i would be giving my patients in
the hospital is wait three months from
your last case of covid your last
infection or three months from your last
covet vaccination before getting the
omicron booster you want we want that
time so that the booster actually takes
and works for you should you stick with
the same brand like have you been
getting pfizer all the time should you
switch to moderna to get this booster
and vice versa it really doesn't matter
it doesn't matter yeah just think of
these as interchangeable they're both
mrna vaccines for covid they work very
similarly okay and can you get the flu
and covert booster at the same time
because it's flu season i'm debating
should i get the flu shot too you can
you can get both at the same time you
might be more likely to have a fever
chills you can take some tylenol to deal
with those side effects
but if you can wait a little bit to get
that flu shot it may be better to wait
until october so because flu season
doesn't hit until a bit later all right
good advice always good to have you here